[Musique]
je
frédéric tellier bonjour bonjour merci
d'accepter cette rencontre pour ce gip
qui veut consacrer vous êtes réalisateur
et vous faites partie d'une d'un
événement qui s'appelle un artiste à
l'école donc nous sommes dans une école
le collège poincaré à versailles qui
vous rappelle des souvenirs je crois ben
oui j'ai été
d'abord je suis versailles et je suis né
à versailles et j'étais scolarisée ici
tout le temps possible de scolarisation
ici de ma sixième à ma troisième avec
mon grand frère qui a été de sa sixième
à sa troisième qui était aussi au
collège poincaré d'accord donc le but de
cette association un artiste à l'école
c'est justement de faire revenir des
artistes et de parler avec des jeunes
qui sont donc en troisième qui sont à
une phase un peu importante de
lorsqu'elle a été parce que c'est avant
l'orientation et donc vous avez répondu
à cet appel
comment ça s'est passé cette rencontre
avec ces jeunes collégiens
ben ça c'est faudrait leur demander de
verser bien passé j'imagine comme
souvent quand on fait ce genre de
rencontre où ce genre d'événement c'est
à la fois léger et à la fois
très responsable les places peuvent lire
ouais enfin c'est oh c'est pas un petit
truc quoi quand même de même si c'est
insignifiant parce que c'est tout petit
dans leur vie une heure et qu'un adulte
c'est un peu quand même procès par une
acception ou des envies ou d'un dock à
la fois c'est léger parce que ben pour
moi ou n'importe quel autre artiste qui
fait ça s'est chargée d'émotion de
revenir sur les pas de son enfance où
plus de revisiter un lieu que moi j'ai
pas revu depuis ma troisième
c'est très agréable d'être avec des plus
jeunes concept spontanéité que
malheureusement nous perdons en
grandissante poney et en même temps on
dit attention je suis pas là que pour
faire le mariole quoi je leur parle d'un
truc qui peut être les motifs peut-être
va les motiver ou va donc on essaye de
faire des réponses intelligentes quand
même
honnête voilà et de faire gaffe quand
même à ce jeune public de 13 14 ans oui
d'accord et comment vous voulez trouver
par rapport à vous au même âge
ces jeunes de 14 ans d'aujourd'hui je ne
sais pas trop j'ai pas énormément de
souvenirs de moi cet âge là où mes
souvenirs sont peut-être erronée de ce
que j'ai vécu à ce moment là moi j'ai
l'impression que j'étais j'ai
l'impression que j'étais un peu comme
eux c'est à dire un peu un peu sur moi
un peu à recevoir des choses sans trop
savoir ce que ça allait donner plus tard
j'ai juste eu l'impression dans le tout
le moment agréable avec eux qu'ils
étaient très précis sur les questions
probablement plus que
j'aurais pu l'être à leur âge mais c'est
ma génération république alors vous avez
un parcours un peu particulier parce que
vous étiez destiné au départ à être
professeur de sport ouais c'est ça après
vous avez bifurquer vers une école de
commerce où je me trouvais complètement
et large de plus et après publicité
voilà d'accord en fait rien n'était
vraiment défini jeu j'avais beaucoup de
problèmes un peu d'errance dans ses
arénas
ça veut dire que vous n'aviez pas à
trouver votre voie on va faire j'ai très
envie de faire du ciné quelques années
déjà mais on m'avait mis un peu sur le
côté parce que c'était des écoles
privées très cher je viens pas d'un
milieu très fortunés donc c'était donc
s'était d'emblée pas pour vous voilà
c'était d'emblée pas pour moi donc là on
peut revenir à ce contre quoi je pense
lutte
cette association que l'intimidation
sociale oui exact de dire que tout n'est
pas pour tout le monde et si on n'a pas
de réseau pas des agents et vous êtes un
contre-exemple finalement oui oui après
dans intimidation sociale il ya
peut-être aussi de l'auto intimidation
sociale très je parlais de ça aussi aux
offres intégrées de croire que les jeux
pan c'est plus facile quand même
maintenant la mobilité sociale qu'il ya
trente ans j'ai l'impression ne serait
ce que du fait des réseaux de l'internet
de de l'information qui est pluie des
parias trappe assistée vitres et donc
j'étais voilà je me laissais un peu
aller je pense quand même comme beaucoup
de garçons et de filles de 13 14 ans
donc le sport je n'ai pas vraiment
défini pour rire professeur de sport
mais je suis rentré dans une classe de
sport voilà qui pouvait déboucher sur sa
veut ensuite j'ai été pris dans une
école de commerce mais dans une section
plumes
donc ça pour moi c'était une vraiment si
passion d'aller là dedans vu le milieu
d'où je venais ça me faisait vraiment
c'était une vraie réussite d'arriver là
et puis le ca me rapprocher du cinéma
crie elle reste assez voilà pardon je
vous coupe la parole d'ado est ce que
justement à ce moment là vos désirs de
cinéma se sont réveillés et ont pu
trouver une fête
mais ils se sont transformés lecteurs me
suis-je cinéma c'est pas pour moi j'ai
bien compris mais là je m'en approche un
peu d'accord pas trop loin des films de
pub je suis dans sa création puis dans
les chemises sympa je m'appelle je me
disais ça à l'époque josé on peut avoir
des chemises sympa elle n'est pas en
reste ils travaillent
ouais voilà exactement je trouvais ça
serait dans un bureau et après je pense
que de rentrer un peu dans ce réseau a
fait que j'ai rencontré un metteur en
scène de cinéma jean pierre ygout qui
m'a formé comme stagiaire j'étais dans
mon école de pulse des stages d'école je
suis parti dans des sur des tournages et
voilà de fil en aiguille je suis rentré
avec beaucoup d'acharnement dans le
cinéma quand même d'accord oui parce que
vous avez travaillé longtemps comme
assistant-réalisateur 11 ans prenait 6
ans et demi et après au bout de ces
années là vous avez réalisé deux
premiers courts métrages
ouais que j'ai réalisé pendant mes
années de ça parallèlement en fait vous
n'êtes pas mal de choses en parallèle
j'ai l'impression que dj pendant que
vous étiez dans la cub et en fait je
crois que dans ma dans mon désarroi de
certaines années j'ai quand même
toujours eu envie d'allier des choses
sympas quoi donc j'étais en fait j'étais
dj pour payer mes études j'avais un
boulot j'ai trouvé ce boulot je trouvais
ça quand même plutôt sympa puis ç'a pas
des dj que question web par exemple il
ne dit pas que mal des questions ma mère
était caissière tapas dont mais où
laisser passer pas mal mais je dis que
ses pairs c'est vrai que quand on a 17
18 ans j'ai fait ça jusqu'à 20 ans 21
ans
c'est très sympa d'être dit je ne savais
également à la fois le revers de la
médaille j'avais pas mes soirées de
week-end avec mes potes très souvent oui
c'était quand même très sympa d'accord
donc voilà j'ai souvent effectivement je
me suis souvent interrogé sur le d'un
côté de labeur d'un autre côté le
plaisir quoi je faisais avait réussi à
amerrir les deux finalement donc voilà
autant de cartes donc deux premiers deux
courts métrages le dernier ouais et le
l'enfermer d'abord fermer la boutique on
met noyer noir et blanc cinq minutes qui
remporte pas mal de prix dans les
festivals ça
le dernier qui circulent moins mais on a
une offre de la gaumont à l'époque pour
le passé avant batman je me rappelle ce
qui était trop long j'ai pas voulu le
coupé tout ça je n'ai pas vrai paul
thomas sanderson de l'époque c'est pas
grave parce que sam avait gonflé de
de confiance quand même merci et puis je
veux fait repérer par une agence de pub
et là on vous propose on me propose de
faire une compétition pour un projet de
pub où je suis en compet je crois qu'il
y avait mon cas royan complète avec
louis et coup de baguette magique je
gagne la compet donc tôt mon premier
fils de pub je me rappellerai toute ma
vie la cliente c'était un produit de
beauté masculin la cliente qui était la
grande clientes de l'oréal me dis j'aime
bien ce que vous faites j'aime bien
comment vous pensez faire le film mais
vous êtes jeunes il faut que vous
trouviez un très gros chef opérateur
caméraman du cinéma pour me rassurer je
vais chercher le gars qui avait fait la
guerre des étoiles aux états unis qui va
peut-être faire le film avec moi et j'ai
tourné la culoz ain sebaa quoi ouais il
m'en sortir paix et j'ai rencontré ce
gala qui vivait à londres
peter susic qui a accepté je suis revenu
vers cette dame une semaine après je dis
j'ai le monsieur les gros y'a pas voilà
il y en avait d'autres mais c'était
aussi le chef de cronenberg effet trouvé
une belle soit-elle madiba très bien
allons-y hop c'était paris c'est un
marché maintenant je crois que j'ai
gaver le gars pendant tout le tournage
de questions sur la guerre des étoiles
il n'en pouvait plus le même temps
c'était magasin jamais way et après vous
avez réalisé des séries
donc vous avez réalisé les hommes de
l'ombre vous avez réglé un flic et puis
un film est ce qu'à un ouais voilà faire
si intéressant qui est même repassé la
télévision elle a très longtemps et qui
parle de l' enquête qui a duré sept ans
je crois qu'on veut du policier qui
quittera le serial killer est ce qu a
dit georges
voilà voilà avec nathalie baye et
olivier gourmet entre autres exactement
valeur sauna
michel bühler est votre premier long
métrage cinéma et là je crois qu'il y en
a un deuxième qui en production avec est
quasiment finie donc la post production
la post-production c'est tout ce qui
vient après la production post
production donc la production ça va
jusqu'au dernier jour de tournage et
ensuite montage image montage son
montage musique création de la musique
mixage étalonnage effets spéciaux
d'accord tournage durant gros de trois
semaines la postproduction dur grosso
modo un an
montage image ensuite j'ai mon tachon et
on a une date de sortie prévue face à
une date paraît très précis et genre
octobre octobre novembre prochain la
ok et ses films s'appelle sauver ou
périr
avec bien géré in et anaïs demoustier
vincent rottiers oui sami bouajila chloé
stefani et on peut dire quelques mots de
quoi ça va parler oui c'est une histoire
d'amour d'un homme qui en l'occurrence
ces sapeurs pompiers de paris qui est un
accident dans une intervention incendie
qui serait après des semaines de coma
entièrement brûlé qui va réapprendre à
vivre
d'accord je j'ai deux points qui me
fascine beaucoup dans la vie le livre de
job qui me passionne sur va comment se
débrouiller quand le malheur nous tombe
dessus et l'autre qui est la thèse de
l'homme nu développé par claude lévi
strauss qui est vraiment la quête de
l'identité qui est on vraiment quand on
n'est plus rien dehors quoi donc le
cinéma ayant besoin de vecteur très
visuel heureux j'ai eu cette idée
inspirée par plein d'histoires réelles
qui se sont passées à droite à gauche
qui que j'ai glané un peu comme ça 2
si quelqu'un avait un accident et perdez
toute son identité
comment il s'en sort quoi d'accord et
c'est un monde que vous avez abordé de
quelle façon le monde des grands brûlés
des grands blessés vous vous connaissiez
façon évident que le fait est là et
rapidement on se documente en font j'ai
lu tout ce que j'ai pu lire j'ai regardé
des photos puis j'ai commencé à appeler
des instituts spécialisés il y en a pas
beaucoup
il y en a j'ai eu un contact avec une
psychiatre dans le sud de la france un
centre de grands brûlés à
aix-en-provence donc je suis souvent
descendu la voir elle m'a beaucoup aidé
et puis il ya le l'hôpital saint louis à
paris qu'à une unité spécialisée dans
les grands brûlés et un centre de suivi
de soins après qu'ils aient en banlieue
parisienne à coubert où je suis beaucoup
allégés tourner une partie du film
d'ailleurs d'accord voilà essaoui écrire
un film ça prend beaucoup de temps ça
prend de 3 ans donc on on a le temps de
faire ces rencontres j'écrivais je
faisais lire oba différents intervenants
médicaux qui me commentait le script je
discute avec eux ont déjeuné ensemble
ont passé quelques heures à la table a
travaillé et j'ai rectifié le script en
essayant de garder c'est toujours ce qui
est compliqué quand on a des conseillers
techniques très pointues sur un sujet où
on ne l'est pas à soi même ces incidents
de garder l'histoire que je voulais
raconter derrière c'est à dire un homme
qui s'en sort par la beauté de l'amour
quoi est-ce qu'on peut encourager les
jeunes d'aujourd'hui à être réalisateur
enfin ça a l'air tellement dur tellement
compliqué de sortir des longs métrages
enfin vous avez réussi heureusement mai
vous en pensez quoi des situations et
bien je pense qu'il faut absolument
encourager et absolument mettre en garde
des sceaux lui ment encourager parce que
la culture il ya rien de plus essentiel
avec la santé l'amour c'est un truc de
la vie sans culture sans cinéma ça en
voyage extraordinaire dans une salle
sans fiction les fictions c'est pas que
des films débiles qui nous font rigoler
ça parle de nous un film c'est comme un
bon bouquin ça parle de notre société ça
parle de la nature humaine ça parle de
deux des ressorts qu'on peut trouver
pour se sortir d'une situation
ça nous donne des idées ça nous guide
toute une vie il ya des films dont on se
rappelle qu'elle est donc il faut lui il
faut le faire après faut mettre en garde
parce que ouais c'est pas un métier de
tout repos c'est un métier injuste
ingrat exigeant et on les gagne et on
réussit on n'a pas de garantie que ça va
durer c'est un métier d'ouverture au
monde c'est un métier d'ouverture à
soi-même de décentrage de soi même c'est
extraordinaire mais faut faire gaffe
faut vraiment en avoir envie il faut pas
le faire par hasard parce qu'il va
tellement de mettre à l'épreuve ce film
que tu peux pas le faire sans être
conscients de ce que tu veux faire et là
vous avez déjà une idée d'un troisième
film ben ouais que je suis derrière
écrire ouais ouais ouais ouais tout à
fait les pesticides c'est que titre non
ces deux sujets faits pourraient
maintenant ça s'appelle goliath le teint
est provisoire entre venue du prochain
film va c'est la lutte de quelques
militants contre le gros systèmes
agroalimentaires qui nous empoisonnent
d'accord ok bah écoutez on a des devoir
merci en tout cas merci retour à
versailles pour remercier cette action
généreuse là de parler avec des habits
toujours à versailles j'y viens très
souvent donc c'est vrai nom mais
peut-être à bientôt dans la rue ouais
avec plaisir merci prédéry l'en remercie
il
[Musique]